hey
oh ok again a trail
the kira soltanovich hey welcome to the
key result on of its show and i'm your
host kira soltanovich i don't know why i
took such a deep breath on that I know
how long my name is and how much effort
it takes here we are in the studio again
with a sweet sweet redheaded man
wonderful amazing red hair on his head
and his face it's Matthew McCarthy Matt
McCarthy he is not only tremendously
funny but just a sweetheart for crying
out loud but we've you know we've hung
out before we've done some shows before
a lot of them were like set list or
prompter a lot of improv off top of your
heads shows and he's just amazing I
really loved our chat I could have I
could have chatted him with with him for
so much longer but you know you know
Aaron always doing nothing he did
nothing he was just sitting there um no
we had to go we had a great time I
talked about his 11 week old son and his
sons penis of course you know guys and
their junk it always comes up we chatted
about you know our love for our love for
urine and I'll just leave it at that
Aaron is shaking his head right now air
you know don't write these I just kind
of say them I know if I had time to
maybe plan it or maybe do like
alliteration or or maybe write it in a
sonnet form but I don't so this is what
happens yeah all right enjoy my chat
with new dad Matt McCarthy okay well
first I want to ask you do you believe
in categories of I even hate saying this
like alt mainstream comet-like do you
believe in like that's a person that's a
meltdown you know hangs out yeah but
that's only because those that's more
the venues I agree but do you consider
yourself more
one than the other only cuz I've just
play more all rooms just because that
was what I started doing okay because
like I started in New York and it was
like if you want to do the club's it was
you had to do bring a shows or barker
shows yeah and then I didn't even know
there was a difference till I was
already like a few years into doing
shows it was just comedy to me right and
then it was like I just started getting
booked on shows those are just the shows
again yeah cuz other comics would see me
up mics or whatever and be like oh
you're really funny should come to my
show right so it's just doing like bar
shows well the reason i ask ya is
because i like doing the meltdown but
the only shows are down the meltdown our
set list I don't get booked for any
other shows yeah but you would destroy
it if you did like the meltdown or hot
tub or I did hot tub once yeah and it
was fine you know it was fine I did okay
like it wasn't mm-hmm but the reason I
bring that up is because when i first
met you and we were just kind of hanging
out backstage whatever green room i was
like oh okay so matt is like an
approachable person who is very nice
yeah very funny thank you I does not
have this kind of like look um I don't
know why you're talking to me cuz i have
a beard do you know what i mean like i
do know the type of guy you mean it's
almost like i have this beard to keep
people at a physical distance yeah um
I'm not saying I get that a lot from alt
people because I don't really hang out
in again it is i think it is a venue
thing because i have seen um and if they
always say Tommy John again because he's
such a good example right he is very
mainstream he's a mechanic who kills ya
anywhere I don't care if it's just a
laundromat and alt room and improv you
know kids birthday party but you're
definitely right though cuz I've seen
guys and gals who I'm like yeah I can
see why this isn't going well at a club
and like yeah I can see why this isn't
going well at UCB you know right but I'm
talking specifically you because we were
talking about your manager saying I
don't know who you are and I actually
got the opposite
I got the opposite but I understand what
she's coming from because she's thinking
of things in a linear business e way I'm
more like a touchy-feely person so like
when I first met you I was like oh I
totally get this person's energy and
he's so just like inviting like whoa and
have a good time there are some people
the minute you meet them in the altar
rooms and this could happen at a laugh
factory as well that are very like whoa
whoa whoa did you buy that at the gap
yeah we're not gonna hang out like she
immediately like oh I can already tell
your style is not my style well I mean
there's a lot this difference between
the audience because you get I guess if
the alt rooms there comedy fans and
they're there they know that they're
watching a show and they appreciate that
you're trying to be funny where's the
right Club it's just a night out
drinking right it's just something to do
when your I feel like more of a fight at
the clubs yes I feel like at a club in
la though now it's more like hey who's
gonna stop by like it's very like in an
alt room I've been that's a struggle too
because you're like I never heard of you
prove it very true you know I also have
the struggle to where I go up on stage
and people think I'm Louie and then I'm
like it's a double hole to dig out
because they're pissed off with me that
I God itself I would never think that
but now oh it happens to me so often
it's to see cuz people don't know google
matte red head hmm actually think your
email is like something red McCarthy
already well I was also i was on Louie
cuz of that like I was like I play have
relative know his doppelganger we're
like something happens to him in a store
and then they go and watch the security
footage and it's me and he's like that's
not me I saw that episode right I saw
that episode everybody's like no that's
you dude he's like that's what I like oh
my god yes no oh honey right so then uh
what how do you let them down easy you
just go into Louise material might as
well right now I should yeah well it's
like I was jokes I need to be I just
need to be a better comedian
and like have something I have a way to
address it and deal with it right that's
what I'm saying about you is like you're
the same on and off stage where I need
to get better at that well I need to
bring more of the offstage on stage
instead of just going on stage and being
like here's the routine and this is it
but that's not to say I can't improvise
and be myself I can do that like I need
to marry the two weeks I think you are
yourself but that's what i was saying i
know if he's not around your diet being
you i need to be better being made um
you need to black it up a little bit can
you be more black can you say that a
little blacker I've been a ton shoots
where people have gotten that direction
I'm like I'm so lucky I'm just this
leprechaun looking loser can I swear
can't say leprechaun that's for sure
those people are litigious and they come
after you you're coming aksha the emails
I mean to read through a leprechaun's
email you got to get through all the I
attire tttt no one of the the the the
body of the email is usually very short
very tiny but I tell you a leprechaun
sketch that I wrote for The Groundlings
but I think sealed the deal for them to
sketch and yeah you didn't like it no I
had a college search it was in the
sunday company in friend of mine for
many many years Aron Kader do you know
Aron Kader I don't know um he redid the
groundlings and I just it never worked
out well you're just so it's you that I
want to see I don't want you to see you
be somebody else well I was a leprechaun
so I pitched you with a leprechaun in
the sketch I know it's not already a
brawl shoes why not you're being
narrow-minded so it was my husband and I
at a parent-teacher conference Russian
knew we were covered in green green body
you know make up our hands and wait you
painted your skin green oh I commit and
reconnaissance on have green skin I
don't see color
that's beautiful it's stupid so we had
our little leprechaun outfits on and it
was a PTA meeting and all the parents
are sitting around there was a black
couple and there was a white couple and
there was a green couple and there was
at the green couple unreal and we were
talking about like you know things like
how to raise money for um for the school
dance and for like a new librarian the
one one parent says we should do a car
wash and then I was like far tttt we
have a pot of gold or some [ __ ] that
fellow the jokes like around like
leprechaun e stuff and boy oh boy did
they really hate me like everybody at
The Groundlings hated me Wow yeah if I
felt it like I could sense it I could
feel the hatred really yeah yeah so
anyways remind me of leprechauns but um
you on that but I I want to see you I
don't want to see you be a leprechaun
what am i awesome but I I'm a good actor
yeah and that's what worries me I'm like
do people just want to see me do
something else and not be me that's a
concern that's it really you know that's
just like a neurotic insecure artist
thing what do people not want me but you
when you're on stage you feel that
you're just being you anak no no I when
I'm on stage well it's the only time I
feel that is when I'm going into like
some of this you know dryer material
where I'm like how this is just a joke
this has nothing to do with like why am
I talking about this I it's like i
finally my manager articulated that
dread for me and I'm like oh that's
exactly what's going on in my head
because like sometimes I'll it because
they can smell it on you the audience if
you're like oh you don't believe this ya
know yeah just being funny to be funny
as opposed to macys from the heart yes
and going back to the venue's here you
are trying to just be funny certain
audiences like at the meltdown are like
you're trying to be funny we want to see
you work through the process so
sometimes what I have to do is I do my
material that I know kills in
clubs and then I pretend like I don't
know what I'm gonna say right the lyric
I got you you know what I mean or at the
the button else and whatever if i'm
doing like a club it's like they take
everything literally and you're like
what as opposed to like melted like
there's no irony at all yeah at least
for me yeah it's it's too they take it
at face value it's like oh this is who
this like they want well there probably
like why is Louis CK being ironic right
just do your jokes Louie [ __ ] yeah I
gotta shave my whole body that's what it
is um boy that would not do it that
would not change anything we'd the
funniest thing is we don't look anything
alike you don't but now that's all I'm
thinking about is the end that bit and I
know exactly that episode because there
was like a surveillance camera right is
up in a corner and it's so obviously not
Louie but that's the funniest thing too
is he because like he climbs up on the
ladder when were shooting the thing just
like look to the lens to see how it
looks and he starts dying laughing and
I'm like what and he's like you have so
much more hair than I do we look nothing
alike cuz I was a naval commercial that
ran a bunch yeah 20 years ago for uh for
fios vios fios ohio smiles and knock off
of vios the porpoise bios and like
people thought he said that people
thought it was him he said like his
brother-in-law called him on the phone
and was like hey i saw the cable
commercial do and he's like no that's
not me so yeah come out it to you oh my
god yeah how funny you should definitely
just you know you got a dire beard black
and I mean there's lots of stuff you can
do there's lots of things prosthetic
nose or chin or eyes or that's the other
thing is he has a he has a goatee he's a
VanDyke I have lived a dude yeah people
don't know what that means no you need
to get like a Vulcan oh geez just the
thing on the G know I know you know I
have one Russian Jew I absolutely um you
need to get like Vulcan something you
need to do something I need to do
something yeah remember that Brian Regan
bit flippers evil cousin zipper
we had like a scar a scar across his
dolphin face that's what you need you
need to be like the evil Louis CK evil
Louie evil Louie speaking of making
people that look like you yeah I like
that Segway look at you you sent me a
picture of your baby jack thomas
mccarthy man to be reckoned with man he
looks exactly like louis he came i fell
over you knew that was coming come on i
did not you did not um he looks just
like you this is a little itty-bitty
dude he's a little itty-bitty he's TT
tidied how old is he he's I hate saying
how old is a baby because it just sounds
so why counterproductive but that he has
an age I know how many weeks is he 11
weeks oh my gosh yeah this is week 11
Wow yeah holy cow did he come on time or
earlier what was his deal he did he was
breached so we had to have a emergency
c-section and they didn't know he was
breached before do you guys have
Obamacare when that doesn't come with
ultrasounds no we had great we have that
sag insurance oh that is really good
stuff yeah from all those wise bios
commercial he's facing the wrong way and
then uh he had switched and then you
know also like my wife could feel it mmm
him kicking on the side and he's moving
around and then by the time I came to go
time he was he was facing the wrong way
and she had no signs of pre-labor
nothing no no contractions nothing no
bitchiness nothing nothing 00 but like
this is like on his due date or when is
this it could have been his due date but
we wound up doing it a few days earlier
okay on the Friday so is november six ok
but so ok well if you look breach then
yet yeah much it was go time yeah yeah
so what was she thinking was she
freaking out there's a like you walk
into the hospital there's two people you
leave there's 33 yeah we were freaking
out yeah like my first kid
I mean it's also you guys wanted this
kit right let's just clear that up oh
yeah okay oh yeah we showed up without
we're getting an abortion like oh it's a
sister area this is weird um no doing
but yeah why are you giving him to no no
you should just be used for stem cells
in the litter in the letter in the
rubbish in the bin so so but you guys
plans what I'm saying so I always ask
him landed because i remember well it
was it was less it was more we we said
to each other if it happens it happens
okay Boyd I got her pregnant that day no
literally really yeah people don't
believe it but the day we were like if
it happens it happens and then the
timing works out perfectly that's great
I know so good that's the it's it's it's
like comedy when you it's because you
get these couples when you're trying to
be funny you're not funny when you're
trying to have a kid then you get these
couples like oh we've been trying right
if you're not trying that's what cuz you
relaxed yeah and you're yourself yeah
and then like oh anak drop yeah of
course well I was trying for many years
not to get pregnant and you couldn't
help me many many many years show and
then so fertile and then you know but my
husband and I were like when I finally I
was you know kind of had to convince him
know he was on board but you know was a
little bit of like all right it's
daunting it's daunting I know and women
probably are just as nervous about it
but we have just a little edge of like
you're wired for yes exactly exactly we
have the chemicals that are happening
all the time so um it was like two
months so we are trying technically but
it was both both kids yeah two months
trying to the funnest parts Ryan was fun
but um actually it was really kind of
was exciting it's a little bit like you
know like a mission impossible were you
doing like all that stuff on TV we like
hug your legs and [ __ ] and we can I got
a TV or you can I swear do you mean porn
or do you actually mean 20 that
I mean that thing were you like you from
those porn infomercials like in The Big
Lebowski when when he plants his seed
and then she's like hugging her legs and
rolling on her back type of okay yes
yeah yes I did do you did so you know
what I'm talking about why you picking
me out I liked it like it a little bit
of the what for you such a your fall
beans I you put your legs up over your
head I'd like to see hey could do that
right now um yeah you put your legs up
right over your head did your wife
didn't do that no man we know cuz you
guys were just kind of like her like
whatever acts easy like Sunday morning
yeah you we I was doing everything I was
doing everything but again not anything
crazy cuz it's not like oh no won't put
the you know won't be able to make a
baby it was just like all right so want
to do this okay great you gotta track
your ovulation all that [ __ ] you
guys into any of that we didn't do a
thing oh my god he said if we get
pregnant let's get pregnant and then
it's it's one of the first times I've
ever ejaculated inside my wife and I
really sure enough see so that's a
houghton potent man yeah well that's
good then that you didn't do that before
well that's what what the only other
time we we tried that was she got the
nuvaring mm-hmm you know that birth
control nonsense yeah and it made that
made her crazy yeah it's all the worst
and also at one point it wound up on me
oh my god like I like it like I get out
of there and all of a sudden I'm like
what is this thing the nuva [ __ ] ring
stuck on me wow how far and it burned it
was horrifying I mean there's all just
as one area ie look I don't know I don't
know biology you make a left and then a
hard right where are you going with your
penis doc just in there but isn't there
a sign in my own business there's this
should be a sign on your wife's vagina
no outlet like are you trying to do
there's a neon sign that says eats
come on I got it you're wearing a shirt
with a Bible verse on it Austin 316 is
not from the Bible from Monday Night Raw
I'm a Jew I know you know um so you got
the nuvaring on you please tell me you
Instagram that this was before Instagram
oh come on this is back in like oh seven
or eight all right i'll let it slide
that's that's frightening yeah i was
frightening have you ever had and then
she stopped taking she's like this is
making me nuts it was it was like
messing with the hormones and she's like
she felt normal again yeah no I mean
it's unfortunate but i think all birth
control is pure evil it really no one
hundred percent it's it's necessary and
i did use you know when I was like in
college I was on the pill and all that
forget why she never did the pill with
us it was it was again it was like a
made her nuts or something all of it is
evil yeah crazy thoughts it's unnatural
yeah because it's like you're taking
these hormones oh okay right take them
every day and that's not what your body
does it like I hate girls in college who
would get like a shot and it's like
you're infertile for like six months I
was like that doesn't sound oh noes
right they were in heroin ah that's why
that's why we're infertile um yeah they
remember do you member the the Star Trek
thing where they put like three bars
under your skin that was a thing really
yes Aaron you you [ __ ] a lot Aaron try
it I gotta load up I gotta look it up
now but it's like a you know talking
about it and you can see them it's like
those crazy people that put horns under
their head it's the same it's the same
kind of idea lady gaga show yes so they
like just stick them right into the skin
and it's it's a it emits a hormone
throughout your body I don't hatch or
all of it is crazy and of course chicks
have to have it right not dudes do you
know how many pills they would sell if
it made a guy like not able to make a
girl pregnant I don't know why do they
make that there's a switch now did you
see that on the switch that real though
I don't know I didn't I don't click
those articles there is a pill that will
not make a girl pregnant I what you said
is that how you were not a guy good a
bike there's something a guy can do to
not make a girl pregnant you have 0
money she will not have sex with you no
no zero money just do like that
irish-catholic rhythm method nonsense
the rhythm is gonna get you the rib
that's you got a little cats are gonna
get you spot like I thought it was yet
to listen to that song while having sex
that's not it oh I if that songs on
forget it I'm done in two seconds yeah
well that's not gonna work then but you
guys made a baby we did how are you
feeling tell me what's on your mind what
are your fears are there any concerns
well you're in a safe place it's funny
last time I talked to you I said my big
fear was that we would have to get a
c-section and then we did hmm so what
does that tell you what secret mental
projection manifested in mm-hmm I made
it happen why was that a fear um it just
sounds scary surgery sounds scary yeah
minus it also never that was the first
time should have heard surgery yeah and
was it scary it was very scary you know
like cuz i didn't i didn't realize like
when cuz she's in there alone alone
meaning not with me like i had to wait
in the hall before like they did the
spinal tap and they did the why I guess
not spinal tap just the spinal whatever
yeah and then and then they make the
first incision then I can go in why
don't they want you there for that first
incision pizza oh nothing happened why
she's like strapped down to the table
with our arms spread out did you have
did you have c-sections no oh it's
horrifying I mean I was spread out but
just different god bless you and then I
come in and then there's a big you know
it's her whole the midsection is just
draped off you can't see it the whole
team is over there yeah and then it's
you know she was really nervous and then
I was like I had my phone I was like I
was like one we
some music and I put on pennies from
heaven why and then did just that was
the song I hit play and that was the
song and then didn't even get halfway
the songs like two and a half minutes
didn't even get halfway through it boom
the kids screaming and then there is
Jack happy birthday oh and then they
bring him over to you guys immediately
no I went over to where they're weighing
them and cleaning them also just looking
at the wall cuz I don't need to see you
don't see the guts I don't need to see
my wife's organs oh my god but that's
horrifying yeah and there was a student
there was a med student like before
they're like oh is it okay if this girl
comes in and observes were like yeah
sure he's given her a tour like that
this is the liver this is that and we're
hearing that I'm like I where will you
wrap it up lock it down doc and of
course it's like a goody two-shoe
student that wants to impress everybody
and starts like oh I see the liver
starts going over all the stuff oh no no
no extra time plus our OB he was very uh
you know pompous was the best word for
him so like he's wearing the like the
pre you know labor room and he starts
quizzing Isaac so what are the different
levels of the skin and now not the skin
the different levels of of the body I
don't even remember who said so she's
like ah he's like you're making it too
complicated she's like the skin I think
all right what's under the skin and then
what's below that and then she kisses
something he's like no you've gone from
here to here What's in between those two
thats scary country is he from he's he's
from Ireland but he's like got much more
of an English accent huh got a very
refined okay he's like well oh the
McCarthy's well they were Lords in
County Cork here's a map i have of Long
Island Oh Long Island Sound off of cork
where I would sail my boat yes well
dublin it's interesting that ah that
soham is like been doing it longer than
I've been alive yeah and then it's like
you know we come in with our birth plan
he doesn't even want to look at it
laughs at he's like I'll let me guess it
says I want to do a natural birth unless
I can't and then I went to avoid a
c-section if we have to have a c-section
than he like I me
might as well crumpled it up and like
thrown it at my wife's head and then at
the end of the session he's like he's
opening the door and he's like like like
in a movie he's about to walk on he's
like oh and we can't deviate from the
birthing plan laughs it closes the door
and all I'm thinking is like wow I wish
you had to go to lunch with my wife now
yeah oh she loved that where did you
guys find him is he like central casting
it was I mean when it's all said and
done sandy was real he's the best I
understand we start off with 10 B then
it's so funny we didn't even think to go
on yelp to look reviews and then when we
went on this first woman we went to one
star who what who it's her name I should
I say your name well okay let me ask you
this it's embed okay then it's not her
or maybe it is wait is it a hard last
name to pronounce its two last names
together oof all right all right just
say it just like dolphine Baptiste no
all right we went in and it's like you
get its she's a knowby mm-hmm and you
could also get like tires rotated no a
skin peel you get like lasered stuff
done on your skin as well oh oh that's
shady right there one of the examining
rooms just with there was a broken Xerox
machine in the room this is what I'm
saying to you how are you into an
ultrasound we think double-sided I mean
at one point she goes she goes oh you
know you've she's like oh you put on ten
pounds when you should have put on eight
pounds you're gonna have a fat baby
you're gonna need a c-section and then
we're like okay that's it okay we're
done is this um no but our sonogram is
that we went to she was super cool
uh-huh and we asked her for
recommendation she's like while I wasn't
gonna say anything but the woman you're
seeing now he's a little only heard bad
things yeah and so she gave us a short
list and our doctor was on the top of
the list and we went to you know get
back to Yelp yeah five stars Eddie and
when it all came down to it it's like oh
he does know everything yeah the
procedures went like her sheep wow I've
healed so quickly oh good beautiful
incision the circumcision c'est
magnifique now what are you going to say
to people
you know we live in LA who r int
activists and that's just my opinion I'm
not bad-mouthing some doctor I am oh
yeah I am H 0 in my humble opinion
nobody has had a people who talk about
leaving the foreskin intact because
there are people who will now protest
your baby I hope you know this good well
good yeah yeah well they can tune into w
GF y oh god w GF w GF y welcome to WGME
why go friend yourself no friend
yourself um no foreskin yourself over it
bait they presented you with up to lists
men several several articles mm-hmm of
pros and cons yep the list of pros is as
long as my arm right the lifted list of
cons is it hurts meccano I know it hurts
they got hadn't skin off oh well coming
through a birth canal is no tickle party
either nothing happening that day right
is pleasant yes because that you know I
you know I remember you hearing about
somebody like that oh here's here's
footage of a kid being circumcised
listen to him scream I'm like yeah
sounds just like when when he was taken
out of my wife right yeah hey you don't
have to convince me we mutilated our
sons genitals is how people put it not
the genitals well I guess they're all
genitals are testicles but yeah yeah um
that's how people put it and I tell them
and I've said this story in the podcast
before but I'll repeat it because i
think it's worth repeating yeah whatever
you do to your kids privates as long as
it doesn't affect me and my kid right is
fine I don't care if you want to give
him a mohawk circumcision or you are
take nothing off all of it off or you
know clip them in the balls to show them
who's boss whatever I don't care as long
as it doesn't affect me because I got
such a shitload a ration of criticism
from crunchy and I am a crunchy person
anyway so but like uber super duper
crunchy moms that were just mortified
and horrified it was okay that is so
pretentious and
so to get ready as a parent that's
what's coming at you good good bring it
on because it's like show me the stone
where it's set in stone this is how you
have to raise your child oh I like that
I'm gonna steal that show me the stone I
got that from Vince McMahon head of the
World Wrestling Entertainment ooh look
at you you owe me the stove you love
wrestling that's so fun I know I can't
wait to watch it with my kid oh my god
you guys are gonna be like on the floor
wrestling each other but yeah so we how
dare anyone I wish you to like what does
it matter yeah and it's also it's like
this like the cons it's oh it hurts oh
it might cut down in sensitivity it's
like I don't need to come any quicker
than I already do you know amen well you
know what Erin that's what he says when
he orgasms that is highly inappropriate
amen brother amen brother and his fiance
is like hey um my nephew so I've told
this before I love this story yes oh you
know this story yes I tell you this
story you told last time we spoke you
told me cuz we had the surgery has
decision okay so just real quick just to
you know finish it off real quick I
asked him he was not circumcised until
he was 13 right he knows what a penis
can do with foreskin without foreskin I
was in the fence my husband was a little
bit on the fence but he was I was more
like I wanted I wanted all the
information I could sure absolutely and
it and this story really helped me as
well well this is again I didn't want to
sway you but I was like this is what my
nephew told me at he was 25 at the time
you know he said look I prefer it
circumsized I had it I've had it both
mhm he made that choice because Jews he
did it that was his choice he was 12 he
or 13 almost whatever I don't know if I
would ever do that but that's the choice
we made for our son now that said we
also circumcise our daughter
what's good for the goose right it's
good for though I should mention I'm
forcing my baby to wear these very
narrow shoes yes bind his feet now big
time I know and you're gonna get a lot
of crew are gonna get criticism from it
depends who you hang out with and who
you allow in your life but well I don't
have any friends oh you'll be fine but
if your ma if your mom oh my god I do
that so much if your wife Wow I do that
a lot ah I call my husband my brother
sometimes Wow yeah it's a lot of stuff
going on behind the scenes Oh a lot of
that's interesting what do you think
that means I think it means that we have
a special connection and what our
foreplay is our foreplay thank you very
much amen brother ah ah a bee he's
sitting on it sitting on that vibrating
oh my gosh this one this one that
actually what is that what am I thinking
I let him talk one time oh yeah um so
your wife might go to like Mommy and Me
group Simon if she has already started
to go he's still kind of little but like
she'll make friends and there will be
you know one of those moms looks like
please please please tell me jack is
eating only organic solids like there
will be that personal it's usually me
know but it's like there will be a
person like that that's all about the
cloth diapers like that to me is
[ __ ] cloth diapers is your way of
trying to look like you care all of it
is that's that's my opinion nobody it's
all a show nobody is enjoying cloth
diapering wow it's all about like cuz
you're either rubbing it yourself Oh God
or you sending it out to some company
that's sending you back some other kids
cloth diapers yes and that van or truck
is using gas just like everybody I mean
it's all just we're all guilty I get it
I get why people do it and they're like
but look it's a cute little like they
take pictures of their kid and like the
homemade but I made this from my hair
that's been falling out
pardon and like they know create
horrified it's just yeah etsy it really
money on it but I don't know it what
would this guilt that they're trying to
leave themselves wrong or something if
this new little person is not leaving a
carbon footprint but yet they'll tell
you that your 11 week old baby is
already leaving a carbon footprint well
then we should all just blow our brains
oh I agree with you because then where
does it end where's the line where do
you just go okay so can I just can I
just live a normal human life now or
does everything have to be I'm not I
didn't set up the rules like why are you
taking out on me like I'm not the one
who's like making us drive these
combustible engine cars that we've had
for a century absolutely a break yeah
I'm not this is the deal this is how it
is the it's like George Carlin said the
planets gonna be fine it's us better in
trouble I love that bit well on that bit
that's such a great bit st. George where
is it where he talks about also [ __ ]
circumsized very circumcised don't ask
me how I know but sometimes I google
image stuff you know in between chores
hot stuff I love that baby sucks about
like all the things that Earth has been
through yeah and he's like oh and so you
think some plastic bags are gonna [ __ ]
up his planet right I love that bit is
genius hey it's just you know it's we
can talk about something real quick I'd
love this is kind of a tangent I mean
it's still on topic of comedy um someone
contacted me today and they work for
like one of the the big like a TV gossip
shows you know like those excess
Entertainment Tonight those type of
shows right love those shows right and
she said oh we're doing a big story
about this Amy Schumer is a joke thief
thing oh I read that right yeah I know
what she get you to no no no I mean I
don't think so unless she's talking
about kids she never had cuz all my
material is now mom stuff but I wouldn't
be fun if she's like my friend who has
kids and then launches into yeah um I
mean I don't think so but hey you got to
get that fine tooth comb out what do you
think about this
just because it just came out and and
yeah I i emailed her my thoughts emailed
Amy oh no the girl from yeah the show
from the show okay um and I said you
know here's what I think um I think Amy
Schumer is a decent stand-up comic I
think she's she's good she's good but
it's not the reason I bring it up George
Carlin it's not like look at George
Carlin and how his mind worked right and
how obsessively funny he was because I
say obsessively because I'm friends with
Kelly and she she's even been on the
podcast and she says he she found just
bags of like tissues or things he would
write ideas on and he'd collect them and
he was and he'd categorize I mean he was
always thinking and always writing
things down and making notes and
post-its and all the stuff nobody I
don't think ever accused him of stealing
jokes I could be wrong but I don't think
so i've never heard any of that have you
ever heard like anyone saying Oh Carlin
no I mean I i I've never heard anybody
say it but like there is the different
phases of carlin there definitely was
when you get into the 90s and the more
angrier stuff huh you could see maybe he
was influenced or appreciated what Bill
Hicks was doing may be sure but I mean
it was it was it was also at the time at
the time right exactly um I don't think
anyone ever accused but nothing Chris
Rock knows right no one's ever said
Chris Rock you know no one ever said you
know the divine Richard Pryor was island
right you know but I think what happens
is and again I think Amy Schumer's movie
was funny and I think her show is funny
um John Cena professional wrestler was
in train would that's right no played
her boyfriend right play Dolph Ziggler
no yeah a different wrestler that she
dated which was a great and he was
actually really great in that but I
think that when you hold someone up to a
pedestal of this is a great comic
unfortunately then it's like Swiss
cheese he starts seeing through all this
stuff with Patrice O'Neal that bit that
was very very similar if you remember on
her
special Wendy liebman's bid on her
special there but I have a problem with
um there's a bit kathleen madigan did
funny funny bit about dieting and she's
like you know Oprah Winfrey is so rich
and I'm butchering it she could hire
someone to just slap food out of her
face I know this bit it's a genius bit
Kathleen Madigan is ridiculously fun
right she could Oprah could hire someone
to just slap food at her face every time
she wants to eat something someone just
comes over and just slaps out of her
face so then one thing that they
compared to was a sketch that Amy did on
her show called this the slap chef
mm-hmm or every time you want to eat a
burger a chef comes over and slaps out
of your face funny idea very funny now
is that my question to you that's why I
bring it up is that one hundred percent
Amy Schumer stealing no because she has
writers she's a team of writers so you
don't know who pitched the idea who
pitched the idea who greenlit it who
okayed it who decided to produce it
should she have known that was a
Kathleen Madigan bit I knew it was so I
the well that's also part of her white
cuz like when I wrote on the Pete Holmes
show we would be pitching ideas for the
monologue and be like no you know
so-and-so has a bit about that or oh you
know so-and-so talked about that on
whatever so there there is a that's why
you have those channels of or the you
know that something goes through of
approvals of like oh I had this idea
it's not on a me to be to know every
comedians material that's what I'm
saying that's all so you're gonna read
like we're all comedians how many
different things are there to talk about
so I feel like that's a look I get why
Kathleen would be angry hmm you know I
get it like oh that was a really strong
bit that I had a few years back and now
it's turned into a sketch and it's on
comedy central and amy schumer's blowing
up so this sketch is blowing up and you
know she's getting credit for I get it
if that is very very very frustrating
yeah and maybe it was blatantly stolen
but maybe it was just pitch by someone
but I mean I didn't know I'm not trying
to defend Amy I'm just trying to say
like this is not so cut and dry and
that's what I
emailed my friend on this yeah Hollywood
gossip show it doesn't feel like you
know like like when Carlos Mencia was
getting [ __ ] from people about like
Louise stuffer or Bill Cosby stuff right
or that it almost felt like it almost
felt because I mean when it's a routine
and you're the you know the sole person
it does it almost feels like word for
word it's on your shoulders and it's
also something of its Bill Cosby himself
which is a special I would assume ever
not just every comedian his seed most
Americans at sea you should the day you
decide to do comedy you should sit down
and watch obably watch I like three four
things just sit back and that should be
one of them throw a pill and your drink
relax so I pitched a monologue joke for
a writing packet that I wrote and I
really feel bad but I thought it was
funny but it was um you know when right
when Cosby was getting sued by those
women like this is a few weeks back and
then he was kind of counter suing them
for defamation and I was like you know
you know bill just said ladies ladies
can't we just talk about this over some
drinks and I thought it was funny it's a
fun right that's funny yeah whatever I
didn't get that's right oh hey well
that's the struggle of writers it's a
struggle but um just I wanted to go
off-topic real quick because i just do
feel like we can't know everything all
the time right but also everyone's
trying to bring down Amy Schumer well
that's what also happens you get to a
certain level and it's and then it's
like then it becomes people like the
crabs trying to get out of the bucket
yeah they just like everyone's like no
no how dare you I think also especially
for a woman oh well you get that more of
like no now we must destroy her right
I'm not and it's not necessarily
anybody's out to destroy Amy Schumer but
it's like it makes me she's she's in the
spotlight and that when you shine that
much light on someone you become a
target yeah and people even know how
many times people ask me like so what do
you think about Amy Schumer now and they
expect me to be like bitter and jealous
and I'm like good
really yes good I want her to be
extremely extremely successful because
then that just makes it easier for other
female comics yeah to let's say star in
a movie or star in a show or I mean it's
just it's good for everyone that is
whether you are unfortunately a thief or
not or whatever the case may be
origional or not that original you know
you yes you definitely I want her to do
well but I don't want people now to
start targeting her as if she is a
carlin giving her this this moniker of
like you know female like comedian of
the Year type of thing no she's very
very funny but I don't think she's like
the voice of a generation so what I'm
saying oh that's what I'm trying
articulate I'm not articulated not Lenny
Bruce she's not right right it's like
but like it's like we were talking about
up top where's it's like it's there's a
difference between just being funny and
then really tapping into your soul right
exposing it on stage have you done um
have you done parenting jokes yet maybe
done a couple baby jokes but they are
just it feels like they are just like
jokes and I'm not really talking about
my real feelings and fears and reign
phone erable about it you know like that
like one joke i've been doing where I'm
like you know so far my son he's pooped
on me he's peed on me and he's puked on
me he hasn't come on me yet here's
hoping that's hilarious I say it's funny
but it's also great but it's just a joke
it's not why are you being so hard on
yourself because I won because I want to
be I want more I want to I have a lot
more to say that I feel like I'm not
saying but is it because it's new or
you're scared to really delve into all
that or because he's just 11 weeks old
and you haven't really dealt with a lot
I feel like it's just everything with me
on stage where I'm like I want to be
more honest with the audience and really
okay so where my soul about what would
be the most everything it's not just not
just having a kid okay that I'm I
realize it because it's just I it's it
is scary to be vulnerable yeah and I
think I should be doing more of that as
opposed to just being a
clown and being funny okay like being
more like Richard Pryor and later Bruce
and George Carlin even but like George
Carlin is he would do all of it he would
be honest he would be angry but he'd
also be like you ever noticed this when
you put on your sneakers yeah right
right where's like Richard its like I
mean you it's like it feels like we know
every aspect of his life and and write
his psyche in his soul yeah like on a
cellular level yeah ok so then what
would be the biggest maybe that maybe
there is a lot of pressure to put on
myself well that is a lot of pressure
but but it's just cuz I care I care
about comedy and I care about yeah the
audience that I'm like I want them to I
want to connect with them I want to
relate to them I want them to relate and
connect with me and I want it to be a
you know I would like it to be more than
just funny i would like it to be i don't
know i would think that you would have
wore something memorable yeah i think as
a parent right lack of sleep that makes
you vulnerable yeah right yeah i mean
well it's not from that place it might
be just having a son now is why i'm at
this point where i'm like i need to be
doing more substantial stuff on stage ah
what does that mean i don't know because
you want to I want him proud maybe maybe
I don't know or maybe I just I realize
what's important and I'm like I don't
know if I'm doing enough hello okay now
I see what you're saying soon I mean yes
yes so before you were just like make em
laugh make em laugh right and now and
now you're like um you want to maybe
unlike unveil a little bit more like
peel open the onion a little bit yeah
I'm like you know what I am smarter and
I care a lot more than I realize I am
giving the audience on stage so my
head's at right now so why don't you
start from a place of something that you
would never ever say not even just on
stage just even to anybody I know and
start from there almost like work
backwards scary it's very scary you know
yeah it's exciting though it's almost
liberating in a way like I look at my
set and I'm like yeah like I need to but
what is something like that like right
now think of something that is something
that scares you is or something like
feelings that came up that when you
became apparent you were like the [ __ ]
am i doing well I'll tell you I yeah
well I it's here's something I've never
told anyone okay is because when what my
parents came to town for the baby you
know so they were here for like two
weeks or whatever ed my mom did she
change a diaper or didn't she whatever
it was like I am daddy diaper duty next
no I I and I'm almost dare say enjoying
it good like I like like it's you know I
said to somebody's my new favorite video
game you know freaky changing the diaper
like making sure he doesn't pee on me or
in Isla he peed in his mouth before I
left to come here yeah is he gonna die
and my kid did that yeah you know
shooting squirt and [ __ ] across the
table like ah yeah so it's like the
clock is ticking I got the new diaper
ready you know like wipe them down they
said you know he looks a little red put
it a little look you know so the rash
Devon you know it's it it's it's fun my
mom said and I'm the youngest of three
my dad never changed a diaper in his
life yeah like God that almost it almost
explains a lot it's like it you feel
that you know not that he was like an
absent father or something right but
it's just that like yeah that that that
intimate thing wasn't there mm-hmm but
then I thought about it I was like no he
definitely changed diaper because I have
a clear memory of being like six or
seven being a wet a bed wetter hmm and
like one of the solutions was I just
wore diapers to bed I wish I had that I
pissed the bed until I was eight they
had like a plastic thing around the
mattress yeah and eventually what we did
is they
got like this pad you put down that's
connected to this lick alarm and so you
start peeing in it so it trains you to
wake up when you start peeing so it's
like this thing I thought it was so neat
because the way to test it is you could
put a penny on the pad and it would make
the alarm go off cuz there's copper in
our urine I guess or something what but
here's the memory I had because i
remember you know how when you're a kid
you're like oh I don't want to brush my
teeth I don't want to wash my hands I
put wiping my butt in that same category
like oh this is just some boring adult
chore I have to do that I'm not
interested in right and I remember my
dad putting a diaper on me one night I'm
like six or seven clear memory and him
being like oh man go wipe your bottom
and like having to get out of bed and go
into the bathroom and I mean humiliated
yeah maybe this is the kind of stuff I
need to be talking about more on story I
don't know I think it's great never told
that to anyone and I dare where's bad
that you had the better that you know
that April at my dad had to change me
and like tell me to go wipe my butt cuz
I was a filthy young man but I mean I
understand how 9 i'm sure he doesn't
remember that at all I doesn't yeah but
I remember somewhat one of the older
kids from the neighborhood was over like
to babysit we were ever and he like when
in my closet and like found like the big
box of diapers and I'm like oh they're
just for accidents mortified oh do you
think that this is gonna make you um a
better dad for your kid that you can
relate to him like if he's older and he
has accidents yeah yeah yeah one hundred
percent I was terrified that our who's
now 55 year old when we were going
through potty training and all that that
he was gonna wet the bed and have all
these accidents just like me and not 10
0 let me tell you something that scene
in uh Billy Madison when there at like
Plymouth Plantation or whatever in the
kid pees his pants it's like it's right
now even just talking about it it's like
like I'm having such an emotion like I
am mortified for that kid yes and like
yeah like that feeling of just like
what's so isolating so humiliating do
you think back to maybe why you peed
your pants did your siblings p their
beds or their pants not that I'm aware
of do you think what it's also happened
cuz I have a theory for me I was babied
by my parents and especially my mother
for still um I remember being 14 I was I
was in eighth grade and politely asking
my mother can you stop cutting my meat
for me at dinner like was a really
awkward experience and I bet they don't
even remember that either is it cuz she
was wiping your butt while she was high
think it's her I want my brother my
sister it's because she was wearing my
diaper Adair my brother and sister nine
and ten years older than oh I've always
been oh yeah yeah okay I totally can
relate my brother was eight years older
than me yeah yeah are you the youngest
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay that I can
totally right so it was just a different
generation I mean you are completely but
it was also it was like I was not
included in anything it's like right you
know there were like overhearing that
you know when I'm with thumb other
parents and they have the kid there and
they're talking about the kid in third
person to you while the kids sitting
there so the kid is completely oblivious
that you're he's being talked about I
hate that really because I remember
being a little kid and being talked
about like I wasn't even there and
they're having a discussion about me as
though I was too stupid to like know and
they wouldn't let you respond like if
they were like so what smell you
studying in school you use like all well
Matthew really enjoys are no he's like
well you know we're trying to get him
into swimming but he's a little more you
know but I'm and you couldn't say
anything well it's
so it's it's always just a little kid
what does he know ah uh-huh you know
like that's something that I won't do
with my kid yeah kids we'll see what
happens yeah I mean it's just like of
it's it's I don't know what what the
word I'm looking for disrespectful or
just it's it's it's belittling right
that's what it is yeah that you are
insignificant and you don't matter oh my
god that just brings up so my own soccer
yes not I mean right yeah one hundred
percent you feel insignificant that is
such a so hard when X that's where we're
we're at with our five-year-old right
because I think they don't hear so I try
to give him a voice I try to say look
your feelings are legitimate yeah cuz my
feelings were never of anyone's
concerned if I was upset about something
my parents I'm like it's so cliche to
say this but they were like shut up and
sit down Wow like that is the cliche
that you here but that was my life it's
like you're it doesn't matter what you
feel no but I'm scared right now we I
was at a slumber party way too young to
go to a slumber party but my parents let
me go and they were doing like all that
scary like look in the mirror three
times and say like oh whatever what was
her name muddy man Bloody Mary thank you
Bloody Mary three times and she'll
appear and I came home and that was it I
was sure that she was like behind the
curtain yeah you know and so I'm crying
and crying and crying and I'm asking my
mom to come in and lay down with me and
she was just like cut it out and this is
imagine cut it out in Russian it's a lot
more spitting what does it sound like it
it's done oh that's what it is which is
the same word for roast beef sandwich no
but it's they also all the words come
the same Russian just sound aggressive
but you know Peter Stein is like knock
it off like just cut it out yeah and I'm
just like I'm really really scared and
they would not if my kid are you kidding
me my kid is scared in the middle
the night or at any point you know right
I have gone around with his Batman flash
lightning like tell me what part is
scary he's like up there in that corner
and I like shine the flashlight on that
corner and I'm like oh you mean this
like little dust let me get that dust
out of there like all make like a game
out of it and I'll you know I'll make
sure that everything is addressed
because I remember yeah thinking [ __ ]
bloody mary this [ __ ] is out to get me
she is not playing around see I was like
I feel like I would be more cuz i also
don't want a baby him and that's what I
was gonna say my husband his father my
husband is dad hugging him he says maybe
four times wow that's and again no
diapers and my father-in-law boasts oh
I've never had a change a diaper in my
life well that's a little douchey know
the song considering you have two kids
and a grandson who's 12 and now my kids
I think it's an amazing thing it's like
my son lays there and looks like he
looks me in the eye and I'm like I love
you dude yes you don't worry oh my god I
love that there's nothing I enjoy better
so far then him crying and me getting
him to stop crying me being like it's
fine do Tori it's magic like that's if
he's scared to death about something
I'll be like oh it's fine yeah there's
nothing nothing's gonna get you right
but not like not like oh don't worry you
know like overdoing overdoing it not
good either uh but I'm also not gonna be
like that sit up get over it yeah let me
check facebook you know what's scary is
this this only has four likes that's
scary no retweets sod there was an
article when my first kid was maybe a
year old mm-hmm that I saw that a woman
um was checking Facebook and her kid
drowned in the bathtub I was horrified
because she forgot about him I don't
know I don't understand that if it if it
wasn't Facebook it was gonna be
something it was going to be something
else I remember hearing about like cuz
you get these people who like forget
their kid is in the car and then I get
out in the
a filing basement like there's my
wedding dress situation where everyone's
going to filene's one woman she's like
every time I have the kid in the car I
remember to take my shoe off cuz then
once I get out of the car I'm like oh I
don't have a shoe on oh the babies in
the backseat I'm like so you remember to
take your shoe off but you can't
remember there's a human how it makes no
sense to it why do you why are you
having kids why are you having and the
these are the people having the most
kids and no wonder the universe is like
no I have to kill your baby because you
cannot bring any more idiocy into the
world I mean it's true it's like I get
that there are you know things that that
maybe happen like oopsie daisies like I
lean in my kid and I'm like oh Jesus
fist is full of you know lint my bad
that's the most neglectful I have been
to my child I'm not going to leave them
know in a tub of death no no i mean when
i read that of course when you're a
first-time parent you read everything
and you're like oh my [ __ ] god right
just paralyzes you with fear and then
what that's what we've realized we're
like all of this stuff contradicts
itself as well and the only thing that's
really worked the best is our instincts
yes you know yes and if I can give you
any advice just stick with that yeah
because when I don't follow my gut when
I don't follow my instincts and then I'm
constantly excuse me I had salami
earlier I'm constantly second-guessing
myself and then I beat myself up for not
like looking at my kid and going I knew
something was up i knew he had an upset
stomach or something else was wrong or
you know or somebody told me i asked a
comic very early on I was like I was
like any advice it's like for kids
whatever he's like he's like any advice
and he's like ah you know to do you know
I'm gonna raise a kid you know you know
what to do and I was like thank you but
you're gonna have questions you know now
you will and there's there's small
things here and there you're like oh
we'll try this try that right oh well
he's fussy like well try burping him in
the middle of the feeding try doing all
that work so
ok ok will do this like it doesn't like
that fine right it's perfect yeah that's
a good attitude that's definitely um not
a Jewish attitude it's not a very
Catholic attitude either yeah but
Catholic Catholic Catholic fear and
anxiety yeah but it's a different it's
different you guys are all about like oh
[ __ ] you know I'm gonna be struck down
by lightning oh you're already in the
red right when you're born you're born
you're evil yeah you're you already
screwed up right uh but Jewish guilt and
anxiety is completely different it's all
you know matriarchal II driven right
it's all just comes from oh so this is
back to why I think I pissed my pants oh
that for many years yeah why um I think
it's because my parents when they are
potty training me there's no like real
potty trained like nobody in Soviet
Russia is really a book about the best
way to potty train oh and there's nobody
like reading about sleep training in
communist russia right so when I was
little um we were immigrating right like
when you start potty training like to
let's say we were immigrating and I
don't think they had time to thoroughly
really sit down with me and like teach
me that you know sit in the potty and
it's safe because when when kids now
this is something please take this to
heart when kids learn to poop in a
bathroom like a toilet they think part
of their body is like leaving them and
it's psychologically it really [ __ ]
them up really yes so many people I've
talked to their kids though p in a in a
potty or on the toilet but to poop is
like they're freaked out Wow my kid was
the same way so i think when that was
happening my parents just like come on
let's go the train is leaving like we're
like piling up on a train what I mean
I'm like let's get the boxes let's go
everybody middle of the night it's very
secret and then no one is gonna take the
time to be like are you feeling safe
with your urine
right I think it was a stressful time
for me and it was just I was like on
edge did you forget anything there's a
piece of me in the toilet shut up sit
down shut up and sit down and so I I
think that's why I pissed the bed and
also I was beat heavily anyways um yeah
were you hit as a kid no I got spanked
and what's a spank than I admit envision
it like rat tat tat on your bottom it
was no it was uh it was like do I need
to pull your I will pull your pants down
right now and you mean Tigers you mean
diaper my diapers I know I think that's
why the bed would know man it's true I'm
fine with it all right but I was like
when I say people say spanked I imagine
just like they took their palm of their
hand went poop poop poop on your bottom
I was beat with several parts of the
body lest her like the back of the hand
the front of the hand and elbow maybe it
was just coming from out of nowhere no
no it was all provoked no no I mean but
like you'd be standing there and say
something smart and then boom oh yeah it
was reflex reactionary yeah yeah see
mine it was like the culmination of sure
and then it was this is the punishment
get over here and you're gonna get
spanked and now right sit on the stairs
think about what you did oh wow they did
that that was kind of progressive yeah
yeah but very rarely where did you grow
up Rhode Island Rhode Island yeah okay
so New England cold Irish definite all
coming together yeah um I you're not
obviously are you gonna spank your kids
again i'm not i don't mean to say
obviously that's like one of those
parent things that i've just complained
about whatever you choose to do is fine
but you're not going to I don't foresee
a situation where I need to hit the kid
oh you'll want to i'm sure i know it's
hard to look at an 11 week old and be
like one day I might wanna choke you
that being said like I I have no qualms
about disciplining him and being Stern
and Frank and like I was a lifeguard for
many years so I already have that like a
step hey knock it off right
all right good sit down sit no you're
staying there but our lifeguard in Rhode
Island's so that was like what two weeks
out of the year I bless you I taught for
your old swimming lessons oh then you
have a patient's of a pope and like
that's a writer for everybody sit like
for Lila I think back that now on that
now and I'm like you were trying to
their lives like convincing a
four-year-old to stick there for like
all right blow some bubbles for me yeah
yes i would keep kicking convincing them
that you're not gonna die this isn't
gonna kill you could if you don't listen
to me a good and yeah listen up
everybody here's a nice open don't die i
I want when your kid is for I want to
have a conversation with you because you
taught a group of four year old swimming
but when you have to teach just to your
kiss him it's gonna be the I mean I
remember I I did some teaching of my my
niece when she was around that age you
know you hold them right to the belly
and right loading their yeah it's just
everything's different when it's your
kid I bet everything is like magnified
there's just um everything is like more
of the colors brighter and like when I
want to think about I me and I was some
distance exactly exactly gonna keep some
perspective of like all right relax
everybody relax everybody relax that's
gonna be your daddy mantra big time yeah
my dad's mantra was simmer down ah noble
ruckus he was big into flipping the
lights on and off Oh to get your
attention yeah or like there's
everybody's being too loud flipping the
lights on and off that's an interesting
one maybe um maybe i will try like a
bell that my fifth grade teacher used to
do mrs. gail would just ring a bell
violently in your face just kind of get
you to shut the [ __ ] up are my first
grade teacher sister Fran cell she used
to call us babies but she would she
would sing it like she got be ABY like
if some kid was starting to get upset or
like Criers like be a be y ou lesbians
show well she's definitely dead okay
well then she got what she did
served I want to sit and chat with you
some more but I have kept you long
enough Wow and your butt like we talked
for like 45 minutes 20 minute well chasm
say 20 ok 5 25 5 minutes um but this is
good stuff I'm excited for you thanks
I'm excited too yes this is it's you
know I like comedy always felt like a
calling yeah but I wanted to do since I
was small and you know maybe cuz of you
know I needed attention but I also
needed control right but it's a ladder
control sorry I'm sorry you are the bat
ten points 10 I point zero besides this
going out to the entire planet I will
never bring it up again I'm sorry that's
no you should know this is I'm exploring
who i am and the experiences that I have
lived through way that too I pissed my
pants in school on the bus that's the
latest on the way to school on the way
to school out there all day in pissed
pants this is what I'm gonna be thinking
when I hug you goodbye I want to hug you
right now right on my crotch right in my
wet wet crotch we're gonna hug and then
we're both gonna start feeling very warm
like which one of us is being um yeah
it's more control so you're calling this
comedy but you feel like you're calling
maybe as well now I feel a native
purpose ah yeah that's what I like to
ask people yeah do you think it's gonna
cockblock your career having a kid no
because we we're very um Glennis as a
performer as well mm-hmm uh not stand up
but like improv and acting and music
yeah and it's like we've had the
discussion to where it's like look I
need to be going out at night good shows
even if not booked on shows find a show
or show my face at a show now you got to
show your face I was amazed when I saw
you at the improv that night it was so
like ten o'clock at night I was like she
just had a kid yeah your mom yeah yeah
you know yeah I'm and you're like you're
like he's gonna be up in four hours I go
to an
the show or do I go back I'm right now I
hear them you're amazing I know but I
just feel I have you have to
unfortunately you have to that's so
that's so it'sit's we have like this
understanding of you know I'm doing
everything I can diapers bottles
whatever yeah changing and then it's
like burping comforting being there
doing it but it's like as long as I'm
doing that during the day it's like I
gotta leave you tonight right now well
I'm glad you were here during the day
thank you so much right or not yeah
where can people find you my website is
this is Matt McCarthy com mm-hmm i'm on
twitter at mccarthy redhead yeah and i
have a podcast guess what it's about
what is it about pro wrestling we watch
wrestling I want you to look up look me
up on Instagram yeah everybody should
look me up on Instagram it's kirra
comedy I have I follow two people Matt
McCarthy shut up am I would like to my
friend Sean Drella Avery that's it I
don't do anything Instagram but you you
you I follow I'll do more one day all
right sir we gotta go there's wrestling
on somewhere there is what day is it
it's Wednesday Wednesday there's NXT's
on tonight lucha underground starting
next week old man doing here what are we
doing we gotta go let's go so that was
my talk with Matt Matthew McCarthy
redhead on the Twitter also he's a
regular on Conan look for him on on the
conan show and that look for him on my
Instagram page he is one of the two
followers on my Instagram which is Kira
comedy which why am I even giving it out
I don't even know how to login honestly
if I had to log in I would just I would
click immediately forgot username forgot
password I don't know I don't know why I
even started Instagram but I am on the
Twitter everybody at Kira comedy and you
can also follow the podcast to do at all
things comedy and the podcast twitter is
at kira soltanovich again i don't know
why i have to it's kind of pointless but
that's what it is I also a Facebook page
everyone did you guys know that well you
should there
is a the kira soltanovich show facebook
fan page you can go to that and do
whatever people kind of do there you
know there's stuff i'm sure that's done
um hey discovery bay country club in
discovery bay california i'm gonna be at
you on Saturday februari 20th i don't
know if this is going to come out by
then but uh i'll be doing something out
there um I'll have more info for a palm
desert I have a show out there monday
februari 22nd don't have all the details
yet but that's what i have coming up in
the mid to late febuary it's a leap year
everybody did you know that Aaron yeah
yeah something you're leaping I we are
we're gonna celebrate like crazy i have
my every for yearly p ur party you know
you know how those are I watch a lot of
quantum leap yep quantum leap happens um
the kids toy leapster is a big hit in my
house for a frog yes it is um we'd we
have a Kwanzaa broom everybody leaps
over that I'm really stretching now I
really don't know why I can't keep good
no I think if you jump a broom or
doesn't mean you're married yeah yeah
okay yeah that's what happens we leap
over that um yeah it's a leap here so
you know party city is gonna have all
their leap year accessories to decorate
all right I don't know what that is what
else is happening information I wanted
to give you guys about my special signed
sealed delivered it is we have a
distribution deal that's exciting I will
have more info but I just wanted to give
everyone an update i know haven't really
brought it up in a long long time but my
one-hour special that i shot was about
seven and a half ish months pregnant
it's called you did this to me we
crowdfunded we raised money we worked
really hard and blood sweat and tears to
make it happen
I it's official we do have a
distribution deal so i'll give you more
info as i have it but i just wanted to
share that with everyone here because a
lot of the listeners were a part of that
and helped make that possible if they're
even still listeners will see will check
we don't know but I do you listen Thank
You Erin and I'm glad everyone else is
listening as well and i'll talk to you
next time